les tensions dans plusieurs villes en
France suite à la mort de Nael 17 ans
tué par un policier à Nanterre
Argenteuil à Asnières-sur-Seine à
Boulogne-Billancourt
à Clichy-sous-Bois à Colombes
à Gennevilliers
à Mantes-la-Jolie
à Montfermeil
au Mureaux à Suresnes
à Villeneuve-la-Garenne
selon l'AFP des troubles ont également
été constatés à Mulhouse Dijon ou encore
Bordeaux 31 personnes ont été
interpellées en France dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi suite à cette tension a
annoncé le ministère de l'Intérieur une
quarantaine de voitures ont été brûlées
et 24 policiers ont été légèrement
blessés selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur au moins 2000 policiers et
gendarmes devraient être mobilisés ce
mercredi soir en région parisienne
contre 1200 mardi soir